- [Instructor] As we saw
in the last several videos,
the Roman Republic that
was established in 509 BCE,
it finally met its end with
the rule of Julius Caesar.
We talk about Julius Caesar
crossing the Rubicon,
becoming dictator for life,
and then he's assassinated
because of the power he
was able to accumulate
in 44 BCE, on March
15th, the Ides of March.
That throws Rome into a civil war.
Eventually it becomes a
battle between Augustus,
or at the time, Octavian, versus
Mark Antony and Cleopatra.
Octavian is able to be victorious.
And, on 27 BCE, he is
declared, or this is the date
that historians often use as the beginning
of him officially being emperor.
This period from 27 BCE,
with Augustus being emperor,
all the way to 180 CE, so
this roughly 200-year period,
this is a relatively good
time for the Roman Empire.
As we will see, there is
still a lot of conflict,
there is still a lot of bloodshed,
but it is a relatively stable period.
It is also referred to as Pax Romana,
or the Roman Peace.
What we see pictured here,
these are most of the Emperors
of that roughly 200-year period.
Augustus proves to be a
relatively good administrator.
He lays a good foundation for
the next several hundred years
of the Empire.
The Roman Empire officially
being ruled by an Emperor.
It's eventually going to meet its demise,
the Western Empire, at least, in 476 CE,
so, it's gonna go for roughly 500 years,
and Augustus lays a
strong foundation for it.
He's viewed as a strong administrator.
He really builds a lot of institutions.
From a historical
perspective, it's worth noting
that Jesus was born under Augustus's rule.
Most historical views are Jesus was born
in some place between 4 BCE and 6 BCE.
Now, Augustus was followed by Tiberius.
Tiberius, here, was both
Augustus's step-son,
and he married Augustus's daughter,
so he was a step-son, and son-in-law.
He also proved to be a
relatively capable emperor.
You can see Augustus
had a fairly long rule.
He took power in his 30s, and
his power ended in his 70s.
Tiberius, too, had a fairly long rule.
From a historical point of view,
or even a Biblical point
of view, it's worth noting
that Jesus would have been
crucified under Tiberius's rule.
The Roman Emperor referred to
in the New Testament is Tiberius.
It would have been his
governor, Pontius Pilate,
who orders the crucifixion of Jesus.
Now, after Tiberius, you
have his great-nephews,
or his great, great-nephew,
and you can see they're all
not directly related, but
they're all kind of family.
His great, great-nephew is Caligula.
Caligula, that's his nickname,
is a bit of an infamous figure,
one of the infamous figures,
in history amongst the Roman Emperors
'cause he's really viewed
as a sadist, as a pervert.
He's known for killing
people just for fun,
and he is quickly assassinated.
His term only, or his power,
only lasted for several years.
Then, in his place is
put his uncle, Claudius.
After Claudius comes another
infamous figure of history,
and that is Nero.
Nero, he's known for, Rome had
a significant fire in 64 AD.
Many of the Roman citizens
believed that Nero did it
intentionally to clear
out space for a palace.
Significant number of
Romans died in that fire.
He killed a ton of people,
including his mother.
He's maybe most famous for
persecuting Christians.
There's some accounts that
he would dip them in oil
and set them on fire in his garden
just as a source of light.
These people, to say that
they were insane, or demented,
or sick, normally I try to
avoid making any judgement
on some of these historical
figures, but both Caligula,
and Nero, if we believe the accounts
that we get from that period,
and shortly after that period,
were not, by any stretch of
the imagination, good people.
Nero eventually does commit
suicide, and, with Nero's end,
you actually have the end of
the Julio-Claudian dynasty.
Let me write that down,
Julio, Julio, Claudian, Claudian dynasty.
The reason why it's called
the Julio-Claudian dynasty
is that all of these
characters, let me circle them,
or underline 'em.
All of these characters right over here
are essentially from the same family.
They're descended from both
the Julian line, Julius Caesar,
and the Claudian family.
That's why it's called the
Julio-Claudian dynasty.
Now, at the end of the
Julio-Claudian dynasty,
you have a new dynasty, Vespasian.
There's a short civil
war, so the Pax Romana
is not without some war and bloodshed.
In fact, this whole time,
there's a lot of relatives being killed,
people who might threaten
the Emperor being killed,
and that's just talking
about the Romans, themselves.
They're constantly fighting
the Germanic tribes,
and groups in the Middle East,
and taking more, and
more, and more territory,
and these are extremely bloody thing.
They're constantly enslaving people.
The Roman Empire sometimes it
looks like this neat, clean,
idealistic thing, but there was a lot of
enslaving of people, destroying of towns.
Killing people out of paranoia, or really
just out of the joy of killing,
if you take the case of Caligula, or Nero.
Then, you have the Flavian dynasty.
I don't have the three Flavian Emperors
depicted right over here.
You have Vespasian, you have
Titus, and you have Domitian.
Of note, the Colosseum.
The famous Colosseum in Rome
was built during their time.
They're also known for the destruction of
the second temple in Jerusalem.
Then, after that, you
have what historians,
and especially Niccolo Machiavelli,
so this is many centuries
later, called the Good Emperors.
The Good Emperors are these characters,
let me square them off right over here.
And these are really
the last five emperors
of the Pax Romana.
We should even use the term,
Good, maybe in quotation marks,
because for Rome's enemies,
for the slaves of Rome,
for the people who were
thrown into the Colosseum
just because they were a prisoner
of war, or they committed
some simple crime, the Roman
Empire didn't seem good.
The reason why they were viewed good
is they were viewed as
able administrators.
They continued to expand the Roman Empire.
Trajan in particular, the
peak of the Roman Empire
comes, in terms of Geography,
comes under Trajan's rule.
That's this map right over here.
This is the largest geographic extent
that the Roman Empire takes on.
Trajan is succeeded by Hadrian,
most known for Hadrian's Wall.
He had the upper-bound
of the Roman Empire.
Then, the Pax Romana ends
with Marcus Aurelius,
who is viewed as a, he's
actually wrote meditations.
He's a philosopher-emperor.
He's viewed as one of the
last great stoic philosophers.
With that, you have the end
of this period of Pax Romana.
As we'll see in the next few videos,
we then start really
getting into the decline of
at least the Western Roman Empire,
as we'll see the Eastern
Roman Empire outlives the West
by a good thousand years.